- Hi everyone. Today is the
day we would have gathered
on Old Campus to celebrate
our achievements as a class.
We wish we could all be together,
but we hope you've still
been able to enjoy,
reminisce and celebrate our
class over this past week.
We have found many new
ways of celebrating,
but we've also kept many traditions.
One of the traditions we are
excited to be carrying on
is the announcement of our
classes' prize winners.
Although we will be
honoring these recipients
when we meet again for
our in person ceremony.
Please join us now in congratulating them
on their incredible achievement.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations to all of our winners
and to the entire Class of 2020.
Tomorrow we will officially
become graduates of Yale College
when President Salovey
confers our degrees.
- This is a particularly noteworthy year,
as it is the 50th anniversary
of co-education at Yale,
and the 150th anniversary of co-education
at the university as a whole.
In this spirit, we are
delighted to announce
our renowned Class Day
speaker, Dr. Jean Bennett,
one of the first women to
graduate from Yale College.
Dr. Bennett is a true pioneer
in the field of gene therapy,
and has dedicated her career
to restoring eyesight.
As a daughter of a Yale professor,
Dr. Bennett immersed herself
in the life of the university
long before she became a Yalie herself
After graduating from Yale in 1976,
with a Bachelor of
Science degree in biology,
Dr. Bennett earned a PhD in zoology,
and cell and developmental biology
from the University of
California, Berkeley,
and her MD from Harvard.
She then returned to New Haven
as a postdoctoral researcher
living in Silliman College
while her father served
as the head of the college in the 1980s.
She completed her training
at Johns Hopkins University.
- Her most noteworthy accomplishment to-date
comes from her own work on gene therapy.
Dr. Bennett created a gene therapy
for leber congenital amaurosis, LCA,
which is an hereditary disease
that causes early onset
and progressive vision loss.
In 2017, the treatment became
the first ever gene therapy
to be approved by the U.S.
Food and Drug Administration,
paving the way for other forms
applications of gene therapy.
And now as F.M. Kirby
Professor of Ophthalmology
at the University of Pennsylvania,
Dr. Bennett and her team
are working on developing
a vaccine for COVID-19.
She is truly inspiring example
of how Yale alumni continue
to make a difference in the world.
And so without further ado,
please help me welcome Dr. Jean Bennett.
- I was told that many of
you would be wearing masks.
So I tried on a few of my favorites,
but none of them were right
for this, or COVID-19.
So here we go.
Welcome to the first ever in
Yale College Class Day at
home or wherever you may be.
It is such an incredible
honor to welcome you
and to be one of the first to
congratulate the Class of 2020
and your families on this very special day
in this unusual venue.
I'd like to give special
thanks to President Salovey,
dean of Yale College, Marvin Chun,
writer, lecturer and communications
officer Alison Coleman,
and the Class of 2020
students planning this event.
Calvin Schwartzberg, Ananya
Indwa, Nathan Isaacs,
Sarah Geach and Michelle Hu,
thank you for this wonderful
opportunity to share the event with you.
And congratulations to the faculty, deans
and heads of colleges for
all the efforts you've made
on behalf of the students
and their families,
over the past four years,
culminating in the extraordinary
events in the past few months,
and these last celebratory days.
As I was gathering my thoughts
together for this event,
I told my husband, this is
really difficult to put together,
especially how the world has
changed in the past few weeks.
To which my husband, a
Princeton graduate replied,
"Don't worry, it's just
Yale, not Princeton."
Five months ago, who could have imagined
the events that have transpired?
I remember thinking, wow, this
is the year we'll remember
because of the terrible fires
that consumed exotic animals
in Australia, who could have
predicted that the entire world
would be faced with the calamity
of even greater proportions,
that we'd all be wearing masks
hoarding supplies and being prevented
from going to work or school.
This 2020 Class Day experience
demonstrates the adaptiveness
of Yalies, perhaps a virtual Class Day
will become a new Yale tradition.
Congratulations, new graduates.
First, I hope that you're all
taking good care of yourselves.
My heart goes out to
those of you whose friends
and families have suffered
the terrible COVID-19 illness
and to all of you have
suffered the fallout
from the need for social isolation.
I hope that you're all adjusting
and adapting as well as possible.
If it didn't before the
number 2020 now marks
and provides extra meaning
to all of our lives.
I enjoy thinking of the
order and beauty and symmetry
of numbers, the incidental
or coincidental associations
of those numbers and how
they impact our lives,
our work and the things
that give us pleasure.
The number 2020 has held
special meaning for me,
given my career and experiences
reversing blindness,
the number brings to
mind perfect eyesight,
seeing things clearly.
Good acuity provides us with the platform
To see fine detail, to study and to work
and communicate clearly, to
affirm what is really important.
Is a Shelter in Place Order
going to prevent you all
from celebrating your accomplishments
and moving forward with your dreams?
Hell no!
Yale Class of 2020 will
lead the way to clarity
and solutions for the challenges
that we have all been
facing with your resilience,
energy, creativity and brilliance.
I hope your experience at
Yale has been fantastic
and that you've had
numerous new adventures
that you've gained insights
about yourself in the world
and that you've explored new fields
taken on new challenges and made friends
with many, many people
with different backgrounds,
talents, hobbies and experiences.
One thing for sure is that
the grand finale is unusual,
if not memorable, your
experience has been marked
by a new divide in
history before corona, BC
and after corona, AC.
From a Yale history perspective,
this makes the early college
dismissal in April 1775
during the American
Revolution seem trivial.
Although none of these compare
with what we're experiencing
now, I witnessed many
disruptions while growing up
in New Haven and then attending Yale.
During the Vietnam War
era in the late 60s,
there were disruptions on
all campuses in this country
due to anti war, dissent
and resistance to the draft.
In 1970, New Haven was absorbed
with criminal prosecutions
against various members
of the Black Panther Party
that had its headquarters
on Orchard Street.
This case provoked national attention
and 10s of thousands of supporters
of the Panthers arrived in New Haven.
Those were challenging times,
but I was moved by the
thoughtfulness, compassion
and courage of many Yalies in feeding
and housing some of the crowd.
I know it must be really
difficult imagining what Yale
and New Haven were like 50 years ago,
but growing up here with a
father who was a faculty member
and mother who ran one of the first
International Baccalaureate
programs in the country
was pretty special.
My brother, Bill, sister Nancy
and I hung out on weekends
at the Peabody Museum.
Saw movies at Linsly Chitt
took our first swim lessons
at the Payne Whitney Gym.
We did all this unintended by an adult.
My first volunteer job in seventh grade
was to feed vampire bats
at Kline Biology Tower
with bowls of blood, and that
was followed by other jobs.
I even got to test intro bio lab protocols
in advance of the incoming freshmen.
Occasionally, I’d serve as
a setup for demonstrations
my father gave on laser physics
for one lecture in Dunham auditorium.
He asked if anybody wanted to volunteer
to have a wart removed by his argon laser.
I raised my hand.
Another person the audience did too.
Fortunately, I was selected.
My father had a prosthetic
arm behind the podium
that was dressed for the same
sweater that I was wearing.
With me behind the podium leaning over,
he proceeded to burn the
prosthetic arm in half
with the laser.
Although one person yelled,
"Get away from him, he's crazy".
No one came to my rescue.
But they all gave you a hand at the end.
There were countless other
wonderful experiences.
One of the most memorable was
participating in the premiere
of Leonard Bernstein's
Mass with John Mauceri
and Leonard Bernstein in
the Vienna Opera House
that clinched my wish to go to Yale.
Imagine what Yale was like
when I was an undergrad?
There were only four elements
fire, water, earth, air.
Well, not quite.
But there were only occasional
landline rotary phones,
no cell phones, no 911, not
even answering machines.
Webs belonged to spiders.
I used a slide rule
that my dad had given me
for my 16th birthday
for my calculus class.
There was no email, the
cloud was still in the sky.
We left messages on message
boards or notes under the door.
There were no CDs or DVDs.
I had a 33 and a third
phonograph and a tape recorder.
And we used to watch the Evening News
with Walter Cronkite in
the common room on a TV
that had a dozen channels,
only three of which had good reception,
tweets and Twitter's were only sounds.
There were no digital photos.
We use cameras with film that
we develop in the darkroom
or send away to be developed.
5G was part of an apartment address.
Tinder is what we use to light fires.
Grindr is how we sharpen our tools.
Applications were documents that you sent
when applying for jobs.
There were no emoticons or
emojis and certainly no Google,
Facebook, TikTok or Snapchat.
Imagine this on the 50th
anniversary of co-education
and the 150th anniversary
of women at Yale,
there were no women.
Growing up in New Haven, I had no idea
that it might even be
possible for me to go to Yale.
In fact, I remember the heated debates
over whether women should be included.
The female to male ratio in
my class was about one to 10
but in science, i.e. my major,
was closer to one to 50.
For the very few women
of color in my class,
I'm sure it was an even
more challenging situation.
It's amazing to me now
that the Class of 2020
has slightly more women than men.
You likely heard a lot
about what it was like
given the celebration of women at Yale
that occurred last fall.
At Mixers, busloads of women would arrive
from the Seven Sisters,
all female colleges
like Smith and Mount Holyoke,
to be ogled by the men in my class.
Women athletes in my class lacked the same
kind of facilities and equipment
that the men were given.
The experience, however,
introduced me to situations
that I faced over my
entire professional career
where there are far fewer women than men
who've made it to leadership positions,
particularly in the hard sciences.
It has led me to proactive
and mentoring trainees,
whether they be male,
female or transgender.
And it gives me special
empathy for the pressures
and intimidation that
racial and ethnic minorities
and sometimes now white men face today.
Before deciding to go to Yale,
I worried, what would it be like
with my parents being there.
There were only a few events
that drew embarrassment.
For example, my brother Bill,
who was in the Class of ’78,
at Berkeley College, heard that
dad had been seen swimming
with his fins pushing a
bathroom scale through the pool.
We were quite embarrassed.
Dad had been collecting
data on drag coefficients
in different environments
for his computer class
that he was teaching.
Bill called him and said,
"Dad, I hear you've been weighing
yourself in the Yale pool,
"would you cut it out?"
Despite those minimal challenges,
I had a fantastic Yale College experience.
I took full advantage
of new opportunities,
many unique to Yale,
I got a job washing
glassware in the laboratory
of a famous cell
biologist, Dr. Joseph Gall
and ultimately managed to parlay
that into a wonderful
independent research experience
that made me decide to
go to graduate school.
I also learned how to
follow new developments
as they're being made.
My husband Albert, some
years later asked me
how I learned molecular biology
because only the rudiments
existed when I got my start at Yale.
Al if I took a Cold Spring Harbor course,
very few of the tools, for
example, restriction enzymes
or PCR, were available.
I just learned them as they
were developed and described.
Some of you have asked why I went
to medical school after graduate school.
Honestly, I'm living proof
that you can alter your career
trajectory as circumstances change.
I realized that as recombinant DNA tools
are being developed, that it
might eventually be possible
to treat disease at its root.
I had met somebody who
was planning to do this,
and I decided that's what I wanna do.
How else do you learn
about the diseases amenable
to treatment than to go to medical school?
On our first day of medical school,
the dean spoke to us
about a terrible disease,
a disease that didn't even have a name
that was affecting
Haitians and homosexuals.
During our clerkships, my fellow students
and I were in the trenches, night and day.
Taking care of dying young
men, drawing blood gases
doing cultures of every bodily fluid
with barely any protective gear.
At our graduation ceremony, my classmates
and newlywed husband,
Albert McGuire was selected
to give the class commencement speech
where he described our experience learning
about this devastating disease
which had recently been
given a name, HIV/AIDS.
I can't help but think
back to those days now
with the current pandemic in mind.
Of course, current evidence
shows that SARS-CoV-2
is far more infectious and more
immediately deadly than HIV.
But like SARS-CoV-2, we didn't know much
about the biology of HIV.
We didn't have a treatment.
It will take time but
hopefully not too much time
to learn what to do to treat
and prevent COVID-19 disease
and we're on our way.
In any case, what Albert and I learned
is that medical training
prepares people to work
at a high level with
incredible stress and endurance
and to put the patient first.
We've seen this recently
starting in Wuhan,
then Lombardy and recently New
York City and other cities.
Many of our medical school classmates
including Dr. Nancy Brown,
the distinguished new dean
of Yale Medical School, and
also a Yale College alumna
are leading these battles.
Another one of the first
Yale College Coeds,
Dr. Nancy Berliner is leading
the charge at the Dana Farber
and Brigham and Women's Hospital in Boston.
These leaders and others and
the thousands of doctors,
nurses and support staff
working day and night
are our heroes.
If you talk to them,
although many are terrified
and exhausted, they say
they're just doing their job.
Students asked me how does
one become a gene therapist,
gene therapy was still a fantasy
when I finished medical school,
so I had to develop my own training plan.
I was fortunate to experience
the Yale campus again
during my first year of that training plan
and the lab of the Yale
Medical School dean at the time
Dr. Leon Rosenberg, while
my husband Al completed
a surgery internship, we
had the unique opportunity
to become Sillimanders for that year
while my father was master,
now known as Head of College.
This allowed me to meet
many amazing students,
many of whom have stayed
in touch with my family.
And further training at Johns Hopkins,
we narrowed in on our
target tissue, the retina.
It was at UPenn, where we
were able to turn the fantasy
of using genes to treat
disease into a reality.
Of course, to carry out gene therapy,
you need to know the genes
and how to deliver them.
At that point, we lacked both the genes
and the tools to deliver
them efficiently and safely
to organs or animals.
Did that stop us?
No way.
That's where naiveté
and energy are an asset.
What was it like in those early days?
We did our first studies in biohazard gear
such as what you commonly
see now in the news,
in cubicles with animals with potentially
deadly infectious diseases.
This is because no one
knew whether the reagents
we were testing were
safe, we de-risk them.
We figured out how to
accomplish the surgical delivery
of gene therapy reagents to the retina,
evaluate immune response and
stability of gene transfer,
what models would be best
and how to evaluate function
and safety of our newly delivered genes.
The science was the easy part.
Other issues were more challenging,
such as trying to get a
foothold on the faculty ladder.
The odds were and continue
to be particularly low
in the sciences for a woman
at times with the demands
and also didn't desire to
be with my three children
who were then under six years of age,
it seemed impossible to compete.
I scoured my institution
for female role models
and I found only two
female full professors.
Numerous other female
scientists had been discouraged
from proceeding and
ended up running the labs
of their male colleagues.
One of the two female
professors who had made it
told me that her idea of a summer vacation
was to leave the lab at 5p.m
during the last week of August,
most other day and she left at 11p.m.
Both of them told me that
they decided long ago
never to have children.
Well, I had kids, so I had
to just try to defy the odds.
What did I have to lose?
We found in our studies
that we can make puppies
that had been born blind,
see for the very first time.
This was through a one time
delivery of the correct copy
of their defective gene
to their blind retinas.
It was a eureka moment to see
a puppy curled up in a corner
scared of bumping into something
because it couldn't see and
then to see it running around
catching toys and playing
with its sighted friends
after a single treatment.
We realized the importance
of this finding immediately
as did laymen. One of
the gene therapy dogs,
Lancelot, appeared on Good Morning America.
He attended dinner dances
at the New York Hilton
and presented his story
three different times
to Congress about the importance
of biomedical research.
He and other canine
participants ended up living
to old age still seeing
two of them in our home.
We adopted them at the end of the study.
Of course our thought was,
wouldn't it be incredible
to make blind children see, we
immediately started planning,
but had not anticipated a
disaster in the gene therapy field
would bring everything
to a screeching halt.
The disaster was the death of
the first gene therapy patient
with another disease and
not one of our patients.
But it was at my own institution.
This was damning for the
field of gene therapy.
The FDA halted all gene therapy trials,
and there were public
meetings and scathing letters.
All of the funding dried
up, gene therapy companies
went broke and investigators
abandoned their projects.
Because of the inhospitable
climate for gene therapy,
there were now numerous
hurdles in our way.
The safety constraints
had been ratcheted up
so that there were 13 different committees
to navigate conflict of interest,
pharmacy devise, et cetera.
And then even a committee
overseeing those committees
before we could even complete
the institutional paperwork.
We had no funding.
But we were fortunate to have an advocate
and Dr. Katherine High of
The Children's Hospital
of Philadelphia, CHOP.
CHOP realize that the majority
of pediatric onset diseases
are genetic in origin and
decided to invest in it.
We perfected our reagent
showed that it reproducibly
and reliably restored
vision in our animal models
and was safe, and we addressed
one challenge after another.
These included legal issues
about inclusion of children
in clinical trials, developing
new outcome measures,
establishing statistical
analysis protocols
for demonstrating efficacy
in this rare disease,
and addressing all the unknowns relative
to rational gene therapy.
Some of these seem strange
in retrospect, for example,
what items should be included
in the informed consent.
Would blind individuals
find it distressing
to be able to see after treatment?
If so we could offer to remove
their newly gained vision,
something that seemed
unthinkable to the subjects.
Would the gene therapy
reagent have the potential
of being passed on to offspring?
We and the parents chuckled as we made sure
that the eight year old
boys in our study knew
that they would not be
allowed to father children
for the next year.
There's only been one gauge
of success, the eye chart
that doesn't work for the blind.
Instead, I assembled an
obstacle course with steps,
turns and doors before
surgery, the patient failed
after it they navigated
perfectly, that convinced the FDA.
We initiated our human
clinical trial in October 2007,
the father of one of your
Yale 2020 classmates,
Emma Pierce, assisted.
The volunteers described
numerous new things
that they could see.
However, we remained cautious until
we had the first objective data in hand.
When I first saw the definitive
data after graphing it out
late one night, I ran and woke
Al up to tell him. It was 3a.m.
But he didn't mind being woken for this.
In the glow of this
success, my father asked me
whether this work might
benefit the two blind students
he had known in Silliman.
I told him, "Dad, the
chances are really slim
"because this gene defect is rare.
"It probably wouldn't help them."
A few months later, my father died.
And then shortly after his
death, I received a message
that the blindness of those
two individuals was due
to the very gene defect
that we were studying.
Although when we started,
we just wanted to see
if this would work, we
realized that once it did work,
we had to follow it to the
very end, drug approval
so that others could benefit.
Of course, we had not received
any training in this process,
nor was there a path.
However, we persevered with
every obstacle thrown our way.
It was an emotional moment
when we received unanimous
approval by the FDA for the
drug Luxturna in December 2017,
and then worldwide the following year.
We were truly the fortunate
ones to be able to witness
the dramatic life changes experienced
by these courageous pioneers.
Being able to put aside their
Braille books and blind canes,
go to school, get a job,
see their children's
faces for the first time,
live independently,
ski, hike, you name it.
We were so lucky to be in the
situation to know these people
and to witness such improvements
in their vision in lives.
My husband routinely treats
people with this inherited
blindness now with this
first approved gene therapy,
we never tired of hearing their
stories of what they can do
now that they can see well,
and we've been working
to develop the next
generation of gene therapies.
With the current coronavirus situation,
I, like scientists here at Yale
and all over the world I've
had to shut down my lab
as only research relevant
to COVID-19 has been declared essential.
This is where some of my Yale experience
and grit and determination kicked in.
After a few days of anxiety,
shock and depression,
I began reading what is known
about the molecular biology,
virology, immunology and
pathology of SARS-CoV-2,
I started talking to one
of the lead collaborators
who himself is a Yale College graduate,
and who I learned recently has a daughter
Sara in this class,
congratulation Tabins.
We discussed how to apply
and pivot our expertise
and resources start working on this.
It didn't take long for us to
establish the preliminary set
of studies aiming to develop
a safe and effective vaccine.
We have no guarantee if
we will be successful,
but if we don't try we
won't have anything.
This effort has energized me
and I'm sure this resonates with you.
We do not want to have a future
overshadowed by coronavirus.
I know that at some point
we will be able to get back
to the projects we put on hold.
In the meantime, each of
us can try to figure out
how to apply our skills the best
or to do what we can to contribute.
I truly believe that my
Yale education prepared me
to reconfigure when appropriate
and take on challenges
as they appear. To have the
bold hopes, perseverance,
determination, thick skin and patience
to see projects through.
Some members of your class have asked me
whether they'll ever see
their friends from Yale again.
Graduates, not a problem.
I've stayed in touch with
faculty members and friends
from numerous Yale experiences.
From the dining hall, roommates, classes,
the Yale Symphony, from
attending performances
and museums and athletic events.
I've rekindled connections at reunions,
my undergraduate friends and
I have shared life events,
weddings, births of children,
promotions, shows, concerts,
career changes, sad events.
They're like extended family.
In fact, some of the
first friends I contacted
when the pandemic hit were my
Yale undergraduate friends.
Those relationships are
enduring and ever expanding.
We are all now faced with an
opportunity for reflection.
The world has been so divided
but for once our stress
is the same stress, something
that binds us together.
Our views of safety have changed.
Instead of being scared of others,
we worry about being the
unwitting mules of harm.
Being Mary Mallon, aka Typhoid Mary,
the cook who silently spread typhoid fever
to more than 50 people in the early 1900s.
Conversely, those of us
who have been healthy
don't want to experience the disease.
We or at least most of us
have been following guidelines
for social distancing
and protective steps. [dog barks]
Who would have thought that
seeing everyone wearing masks
would be the new norm?
Now when I see images of
groups of people without masks,
I wonder where are those
people that they are not concerned?
It is heartening to see the
solidarity concern and respect.
Some of the changes I've
noticed in recent weeks
are truly beautiful.
It seems to me that people
have become more outgoing
and more caring.
They're bringing groceries
and medicines to those in need
lending a helping hand, even if there are
some kooky elements like stop
stockpiling toilet paper.
I've had the opportunity to meet neighbors
we never even knew existed
while walking my dogs.
People call out from across the street
to ask how the family's doing.
People are more appreciative and thankful.
We see images and videos of
groups cheering and clapping
for people who've saved lives.
Instead of going out to
restaurants, people are cooking
and trying new recipes despite worries
about gaining the COVID-20.
Children have time to be kids
instead of rushing from event to event.
They're riding their bikes
around the neighborhood
without helicopter parents.
Part of the reason is likely
that there's no traffic
and it's much safer for them.
Plus, maybe their parents
don't mind having a few minutes
of peace and quiet.
It is nice to be able to take
advantage of new technologies
to meet instead of flying everywhere.
The sky is even bluer for it and our world
has less machine made noise.
I hear reports of dolphins
swimming in the canals of Venice,
and I'm skeptical of them
until I step outside my home
and I see a fox running
across my neighbor's yard
and a deer with her
fawn walking slowly down
the middle of the street.
The IT world has proven
over and over again
and right now in fact
shout out to Rick Leone
and Douglas Forbush that
they can keep us all connected,
whether it be in classes,
performances, art exhibits,
lectures, births or Class Day.
It's strange and confusing
and funny and surreal
and endearing and heartening,
giving us all a feeling of connection.
We now have the demonstrated opportunities
for carrying out Virtual
Education, telemedicine,
thesis defenses and
for sharing artwork,
we can take virtual tours of Notre Dame,
we can attend livestream
performances of symphonies.
Attendance has never been higher.
We see Lady Gaga, Mick
Jagger, Taylor Swift
and other stars performing
in their basements,
and we're entertained
by comedians appearing
in their kitchens on Saturday Night Live.
There's baseball in
ballparks without fans
online support groups, dance
classes, weightlifting,
body combat, improvisation, memes,
and I even saw poker games
on the Yale Facebook page.
The coronavirus cruelly robbed you
of those very last days at Yale.
This is a huge deal and certainly nothing
that any of us anticipated.
However, do not despair.
This terrible experience has
created new opportunities
and your class will shape things to come.
This event will galvanize
you all to put your talents,
expertise, imagination
and passions to good use.
You have a huge opportunity for a reset
to re-engineer our world.
Disaster makes the
impossible become possible.
The pandemic has shown us
how quickly things can change
if they must.
We are still in shock,
adjusting, grieving, mourning
and recalibrating, but Class of 2020,
soon we will need you all to step in
and roll up your sleeves.
The way one deals with obstacles
is often what sets apart
those that accomplish their
goals and those who don't.
Of course, a little luck
helps but if we don't try,
we don't succeed.
Although it can be frustrating,
we all learn from the challenges
that are placed in our path
and the mistakes we make along the way.
We learn from being tested
and going through disruptions.
We learn how to be independent
as well as how to collaborate
and work with others.
It's okay to worry a little bit.
That's a protective mechanism
as long as it's in check,
but be assured that this
long and winding road
will lead us to
opportunities and solutions.
It may take time for
each of you to recognize
where you best fit in, but
there are numerous opportunities
AC, after corona.
For the short term, you can take advantage
of having the time and
physical isolation to read
and think and to fill in the
gaps in your knowledge base.
It's also important to
spend the time on yourself
to develop your talents,
whether they be to write, draw,
sing, dance, we won't have
this opportunity forever.
Many of you are nurturing,
encouraging and inspiring
your friends, siblings,
parents and grandparents,
what a great opportunity to strengthen
those unique relationships.
Those who have suffered
terrible COVID-19 symptoms
are going to need extra physical
and psychological support
from all of us to get well
and independent again.
People are going to say
we will get through this.
That is not enough.
We need to think about the long term.
For those of you who carry
out scientific research
do not fear.
The majority of you who
have worked in research labs
have had to curtail those
relationships due to coronavirus.
We need you, get ready,
things will crank up sooner
than you think.
For those in other fields,
there will be numerous opportunities.
We depend on you to unite
our fragmented government,
to use your economic and financial acumen
to address financial problems,
to foster business
opportunities that are honest
and not self serving.
To treat our workers properly,
keep them out of harm's way
and give them a livable minimum
wage, daycare and sick leave.
To take care of our precious
Earth and provide habitats
for creatures and birds, to
take care of the homeless,
impoverished, the mentally ill
and those who are addicted
to narcotics. To provide everyone
with a high quality education.
We need to stand up to
bullies and to make sure
that there's no interference
from foreign governments
in our elections.
Remember to vote.
And we need to support all of
those people who bring beauty,
joy and meaning to our lives every day
through music, art, literature,
comedy and performance.
Move over scattered, boastful,
incoherent and unscientific
behavior and make way for
compassion and what Camus
describes in The Plague as being
the most important, decency.
Above all, there is hope.
We have all learned
and reflected on what is really important,
our relationships with one another.
We can all draw inspiration
from those who have surmounted
enormous obstacles to
arrive at our new normal,
and make that even better, more just
and more secure than the old normal.
You're such an extraordinarily
resilient and diverse
and brave class, Class of 2020.
You're wired, pragmatic,
driven, empathetic and creative.
You have shown through the recent events,
how we are connected and that
there come extraordinary times
when we're impelled to
take care of one another
in a basic and profound way.
The pandemic has already taught
you to think beyond your own
past expectations, to reformulate them
and begin the process of becoming
the next generation of leaders.
I applaud each and every one of you,
my heartiest congratulations
and my very best wishes
for your continued good health,
happiness and connectedness.
- Thank you, Dr. Bennett
for your inspiring words.
Your message is especially powerful
in the current situation.
In fact, it's at times like
these when we appreciate
even more those figures who
have been so instrumental
in our daily lives on campus,
and have really helped
to make Yale feel like home
over the past couple of years.
Being away from campus now just makes us
remember how much we value
their love and support.
At the same time, we also
are immensely grateful
to those who have been so key to making
this virtual graduation ceremony possible.
They have put in countless hours
to try to make our ceremony
as special as possibly can
be given the circumstances
and we are so, so grateful.
And finally, to all of our
families and loved ones
who have helped us and supported us
all the way to this important milestone.
Thank you so much.
We truly could not be here without you.
And this is a celebration of you as well.
Thank you so much.
- And to everyone, family and
friends watching from home.
Thank you for joining us this week.
We're excited to continue celebrating
when we come together in the future.
Until then, we hope that
you and your loved ones
stay safe and healthy.
To conclude our Class Day celebrations,
we ask that you'll join us in
singing the Yale University
alma mater, "Bright College Years”.
We encourage you to take
out the handkerchief
you received in the Class Day box,
or the one you might still have
from our first week at Yale.
We now present to you
"Bright College Years",
led by the senior members
of the Yale Glee Club,
as directed by Jeffrey Douma,
and the members of the
Yale Bands as directed
by Thomas Duffy.
Thank you all and we're
glad to have celebrated
these bright college years with
each and every one of you.
(upbeat music)
♪ Bright college years
with pleasure rife ♪
♪ The shortest, gladdest years of life ♪
♪ How swiftly are ye gliding by ♪
♪ O why does time so quickly fly ♪
♪ The seasons come, the seasons go ♪
♪ The earth is green or white with snow ♪
♪ But time and change shall not avail ♪
♪ To break the friendships
formed at Yale ♪
♪ In after years should trouble rise ♪
♪ To cloud the blue of sunny skies ♪
♪ How bright will seem
through mem'ry's haze ♪
♪ Those happy golden bygone days ♪
♪ O let us strive that ever we ♪
♪ May let these words our watch cry be ♪
♪ Where e'er upon life's sea we sail ♪
♪ For God, for country, and for Yale ♪
(crowd applauding)
(upbeat music)